les chéris vous savez maxime gainey a
gagné l'épreuve des poteaux de koh lanta
il est resté près de six heures pour les
poteaux exceptionnel réaux et maxime ce
soir comme dans koh lanta vous avez
droit d'éliminer un chroniqueur vous
allez pouvoir éliminer un chroniqueur
qui va rentrer directement chez nous on
va revoir les images de votre victoire
et juste après je vous dire de quoi ils
auront tous ces partis
[Musique]
cyril je crois que j'ai écouté le
pompier parce qu'il me dit que je suis
resté trop longtemps
bravo maxime il met par terre et par
terre
j'attends sueur mesures symboliques ita
messieurs merci à vous
[Musique]
à l'époque
[Applaudissements]
gilbert je vous le dis vous les crocs
tué mon fils ou continuer et voilà les
jusqu'au bout de lui même
mais gilles le pompier qui était là
gaëtan vous a dit il faut arrêter parce
que là c'est vrai qu'il avait les genoux
qui l'ont fait sans rigoler ses genoux
mon frère j'avais l'impression qu'il
avait des morceaux de deux gigots au
bout du truc de ouf ça va mieux ou pas
fatou vous à vous amassez oui elle s'est
bien occupé de moi vous aussi et j'ai eu
deux massages ça va c'est encore
franchement c'est encore douloureux
c'est vrai j'ai du mal à monter les
escaliers de la vma c'est oui ok il a
fait venir à ma soeur non non c'est un
moment je t'ai pris un petit peu des
bauges
il vous aime tous évidemment bravo à
maxime et gilles foussat hui qu elle a
54 ans à 4 4 11 et le performant
alors ma chum chaque personne a envie de
rester bien sûr dans cette émission
puisque dans un instant tu viendras ici
est une autre affaire
le prénom de la personne que tu le veux
plus voir dans l'émission qui passe est
une laisse partir mais qui va rentrer
charme les bénitiers finition
définitivement cui et payer quand même
quoi payer qu'en mai lorsque alors ben
voilà c'est là que je vois votre
mentalité part aux abonnés libe
novelli alors établi oui il sera payé
mais je peux vous dire si j'étais lui je
ne serais pas fier alors bien sûr je
vais vous laisser une dernière chance de
convaincre maxime de rester et chacun a
peut-être amener quelque chose a quelque
chose à dire à maxime pour le convaincre
qu'il veut rester et qu'il aime maxime
je vais démarrer par vous doc gynéco
vous maximum déjà vous ne saviez pas
comme ils s'appellent pedro donc qu'est
ce que vous avez envie de lui dire ne
m'élimine pas garde mois avec vous parce
que en fait
et puis en plus je vais te dire toi tu
as l'immunité puisque tu as gagné le
top-10 tiers quelle est la meilleure
info dont voici les
et puis ça nous arrange parce que le
temps qui nous donne une bonne raison
on était sur ballons seront pas déçus
c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça alors
isabelle morini bosc
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire un maxi
maxime un jour cyril arrivera forcément
sur m6 je ne sais pas à quel moment
et toi tu suivras alors je vais te
donner un mode d'immunité et moi mon
amitié avec donc forcément tu peut pas
m'éliminer parce que contrairement à ce
qu'ils disent touche une femme d'avenir
pour toi c'est dingue collectionner les
mags web après lui collectionne aussi
mais avec pipo vous connaissez les
québécois connaissent ce n'est pas les
mags même temps les ménages et les pas
de mal à trouver ses débuts chez moi je
n'ai pas ces touches pas en quoi cela m
a fait c'est vrai c'est vrai
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai demandé l'avis du public tient
touche pas à mon poste
koh lanta et vous nous dites vous mettez
le nom de voilà pouvait donner un
conseil à maxime qui voulez vous faire
sortir ce soir directement qui va
quitter l'aventuré gilles verdez qu'est
ce que vous avez à lui maxime je vous
aime beaucoup vraiment vous avez été
très fort et je vous ai amené des
oreilles de mickey à et pourquoi parce
que vous n'avez pas beaucoup l'occasion
de mickey lourdeur il est meilleur sur
les poteaux un fil alors moi j'ai un
petit cadeau voir un très très beau
cadeau là parce que je sais que tu es
comme moi tu galères un peu pour pécho
vous l'avenir
donc ben je les lui apporter parce que
j'ai vu que sur instagram est suivie une
de mes copines non et j'ai vu que tu
avais follow et bac donc ce que j'ai
fait c'est que je les appelais tout à
l'heure je vais demander si je pouvais
lui demander son numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est pas vraiment autant de soirs
l'amitié m alors cet incident arrêtez
d'être comme si on la connaît même pas
vous êtes vraiment des trucs comme ça
allez un petit peu plus loin sans
rigoler c'est quand même amour de saola
oui non mais c'est bon ou quoi alors
mais la tension il n'y a pas une photo
de plein qui ne l'est pas et habana moi
je pose est ce qu'on peut appeler tout
de suite les manifs on peut l'appeler
12,8 ces aléas les ja alors préparez
numéro parce qu'il est très longue pour
faire un numéro et donc vous allez nous
dire après on peut l'appeler nos
origines
oui là-bas vous à la halle envahissent
comme nationale n'y sera new sera joli
merci nous sera à bâle en régie à la
batterie brady s'emballer à l'appel on
l'appelle directement en allemagne où ce
rendez vous sera tout cela paiera sera
sera alors à sera sédhiou et max pareil
convoité très très bien alors je suis
ton numéro de téléphone de la part de
francesca est apparemment tu as vu un
intérêt à me délivrer ce numéro je ne
sais pas ce qui t'a attiré mais ce
cadeau non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais et l'autre cyrano de bergerac là
c'est bon là à les trucs dans l'oreille
c'est très bien se débrouiller tout seul
mais totalement et je veux qu'on avait
des points en commun tu es très porté
sur le développement personnel
un livre de deepak chopra sur ces danses
un livre de qui ne dis pas que je praca
gros dans la pâte chopra et à espionner
tout se mettait cette interview vous
appelez commandé 20 sera nous sera
yousra bonsoir vous nous regardiez ou
quoi ouais ça value sera vous faites
quoi dans la vie
[Musique]
d'accord il nous serait ce que vous êtes
célibataire déjà première question parce
que on touche pas je veux pas d'avis
qu'il n'aurait pas donné mon numéro
[Applaudissements]
méroé calme toi parce que lui là c'est
le chauffeur livreur du tout
[Applaudissements]
le gall s'est accroché pour ça ni le
chauffeur ni d'aller livrer du cac à la
casse sociale est pour toi
vous êtes à paris où sera cotée à paris
vous avez quel âge où sera de 30 ans
d'accord j'arrête ça elle a pour
l'instant ville dans l'est non non non
non non non aucune question pour yousra
c'est lui qui va décider
yousra est ce que c'est votre style ou
pas maxime ah oui complètement
[Applaudissements]
yousra vous êtes tous là d'un faux
casier à tous là tout de suite je suis
sur paris mais quoi mao
je pense qu'il faut aussi longs
différents convois n'ont alors yousra
moi vous savez je vais appeler ce qu'on
appelle plus vous connaissez la roue de
la fortune dans la roue de la fortune a
vraiment il y avait la partie accélérée
c'est la banque et bien et bien ce soir
nous sera est ce qu'on peut vous envoyer
un mot tabou cherché mais je vais faire
ne soit lui qui va quitter le plateau va
les chercher
[Applaudissements]
c'est là qu'on va aller chercher nous
sera et je veux qu'elle soit là avant la
fin de l'émission
mais j'ai une belle crues importantes
oui deux non intéressés on a envie de
s'en débarrasser j'ai une question ne
sera est-ce que tu cherche l'amour ou
est ce que tu cherches histoire d'un
soir la madrasa pas la bonne bouille à
tapas la bonne porte parce que ouais
c'est parce que tu m'avais dit jean
michel maire je te dis voilà dans mes
jean michel maire s'est beaucoup calmé
d'ailleurs il cherche la bourre
également malheureusement il ne trouve
pas sous le coup d'un soir n'avaient pas
tous abattus sur ce jeu tout lui laisser
dans koh lanta il trouve n'importe quoi
il va cogner dans sa cellule sacem
d'immunité t'inquiète pas je te promets
que l'amour nous c'est vrai nous est ce
que vous voulez venir sur le plateau
avant la fin de l'émission
et ben pourquoi pas
[Applaudissements]
maxime est ce que voulait que youssou
viennent j'ai pas dire non youth on va
venir me chercher tout de suite c'est
même ça tout de suite si je pense qu'on
va faire on va faire très vite
il nous reste avec nous en ligne vous
devons intervenir pour vous voulez et on
va vous dire dans un instant qu'yvan ne
vous cherchez et vous serez là très vite
vous habitez ou à paris non mais où une
opel corsa bleus dans cet ami julien
vous savez je vous dis aux
téléspectateurs on en direct et j'ai des
rêves de séquences
j'ai un rêve de séquences où yousra
arrive là tout à l'heure la laddh
entendant badgastein 19h40 hier frédéric
françois qui est la même et là je t'aime
je t'aime alité
[Applaudissements]
soissons vous avez de rapprocher des
sujets comme ça non jusqu'à nommer série
sciences que c'est vraiment ma meilleure
amie donc genre tu n'en sais rien c'est
pas laurie laurie en tout cas pas vous
mais je vous dis je t'en parle pas
vous avez quoi eh ben c'est dingue hein
là ça me fait très plaisir mais c'est ce
qui a toujours une meilleure amie de mes
amis alors on saura qu'on n'a pas pris
la bonne dans l'émission est magnifique
et tous les mecs tous mes copains
veulent vous peixoto même nom qui vous
m'avez pas donné un seul nom bah je n'ai
pas voulu que j'appelle la compagnie
rend la pareille à yousra qui donnera le
groupe mes copains la ceinture si il
faut plus le portable sa grille
oui j'ai un ami qui vous follow sur un
star je suis permis de prendre son
numéro s'appelle kevin oui vous aime
beaucoup
ils font tous numéros connard
[Applaudissements]
mathieu je vais pas te mentir
ouais c'est quoi va accélérer les choses
parce qu'on était le premier en danger
c'est toi pourquoi ce que je pense que
ma team pas de léry quoi ça qu'on a
jamais pu saquer non mais oui mais c'est
l'ambassade est en train d'aller mieux
mathieu qu'est ce que tu as fait pour
maxime pour le mettre en oeuvre au
cadeau alors c'est quoi etc et sincère
c'est très peur c'est un c'est une
invention de ses tares magnéto compile
de tes meilleures interventions au nord
c'est dire si ces cours il fait 4
secondes regarde et on dirait qu'il a la
photo de classe il faut toujours être
propre beau et bien apprêtée lors de ce
direct vous nous n'aurons pas quelles
sont nos épreuves les épreuves qui font
peur mais prônons les épreuves dont on a
envie de faire et on a filmé la réaction
des geeks lors de l'avant-première
regardez c'est pas piquée des hannetons
oh la la puis évidemment big up amel
bent qui apporte ça fait juste les
audiences se dopent sur ne sont pas
communiqués
rien
nous nous sera quand même d'un maxime de
l'émission oui gentil nettoie le regarde
pas yousra sont les téléspectateurs qui
nous enjoignent yousra est la meilleure
amie de francesca on a vu que maxime
gainey la suivait elle a donné son
numéro à maxime
on l'a appelée et là dans un instant
maxime va désigner celui qui va quitter
l'aventuré qui va les chercher yousra il
reviendra après dans l'émission parce
que voilà il reviendra avec you sera
d'accord je vous le dis
yousra n'a lui pas loin c'est à dire que
je pense que le temps pratiquement d'une
pub parce que ici le ton d'une prime tu
as le temps de faire un pari ne va pas
se mentir sur ses 8
ils peuvent faire une émission peut
faire une deuxième fois et plus moi là
un moment j'oubliais je suis la cervélo
tu prépares une de zumba l'émission
c'est intrigant sais même plus comment
s'appelle à la fin dit plus haut je vous
le dis on part en pub à la 40 auront
bien à 90
alors donc les chéris maxime tu va
désigner la personne qui va les chercher
yousra qui quitte l'aventuré maxime
mettez moi une musique de conseil la
décision est très compliqué même un
certain c'est que tu as un peu plus fort
bond belge il a été mon camarade de
route
bon évidemment tu n'es pas éliminés
isabelle tu restais jusqu'à 1h30 du
matin tout comme cyril a pendant les six
heures de poteaux donc je ne termine pas
après ça devient un peu plus compliqué
n'hésitant pas qui est qui
j'hésite entre gens me et jamais je suis
pas non plus
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
jean-michel aller la chercher
je préfère je préviens je veux quelqu'un
s'est pas risqué le seul risque c'est
blanc pour l'audience parce que les gens
sollicite beaucoup ma présence dans
l'émission sur twitter ils ont proposé
qu'on cohanim balances ton post non vous
écouter beaucoup les twittos gérer aussi
beaucoup dire qu'ils vont rentrer chez
vous je vais prendre celui qui a une
très grosse très grosse voiture pour
aller pouvoir chercher yousra je vais
donc sélectionné matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]